I'm with you waiters now wait don't pull
a real weight on me here Bob we got this
be a step above the weight aren't um
where you guys aren't opposite teams I'm
with Bob cuz yeah we switched oh I'm
with Wade now good all right uh yeah
what are you talking about mark let's do
this way I'm incredibly stupid I told
you guys oh that's the ticket you don't
need that Connecticut actually that's
not bad well I'm not even playing right
now where who's playing that's uh Jack
and I are play this might really work
out wait I think you've got a winner
here I think I think this is a winner
this is like I said there's no way we're
gonna find oh my god anything in here
you should you didn't walk past him and
everything but you just have no [ __ ]
chance in hell like this you yeah
but it's open so technically you can see
a lot of it and maybe maybe there should
be acrobatic practice we need rope attic
hot hot or cold uh where you are Oh
almost as cold as you can be actually
you're pretty cold but I ship it what
what does that mean what do you mean was
it mean he likes her ass check that's
what he means
uh uh you're warmer than you were where
you were uh you're getting colder again
though I saw you for a second check oh
wait I see him I see him I see him you
see him yeah I see him were you moving
around way he's gonna getcha oh I can't
move up he's gonna get you like he won't
die he come in get in for a ride hey yo
I ship it
oh I'm get clues and stuff you free
do you have what hell are you 10%
helpful I'm stuck
sure all right jack showed it's not be a
fool no for about 20 seconds Jack was
inside of me yeah sure
okay hot yeah yeah sure whatever yes
sure whatever yeah but slugger that I
usually go okay wait yeah I'm stuck
looking at Jack's victory screen while I
wait to be free
chuckling he had a random shot of the
map this is going to be the hardest map
I know that's gonna be awful what are
you doing you're buying it
you don't hear nothing I'm on your team
stupid fool oh yeah what do you do
nothing okay
hey we should bring back the nose
sitting still rule for like a minute or
over a minute what happens if you're
stuck how about that sorry you [ __ ]
flail around this lots of flus well
it'll probably be obvious when you find
me but maybe not coz you don't know the
map but probably also it is it this no
it's not that's a balk also it sucks I'm
awful at this so far other than knocked
over vending machines everything looks
as it should uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
one of you just walked over me haha what
what oh good I left now one of you walks
on top of me littering works on me
father one was this uh scaffold thing so
I think must have been you Wyatt just
jumped down off a ladder when he said
that so he enlisted I always before that
I left oh it was a little August okay so
good neither one of us I was a tiny
little box anyone top so the rule is if
you're a small object you must keep
moving around is that the thing yeah
sure
oh there's a whole other section now
Christ yeah they're this map is
never-ending what are you in action are
you in the section that I made us I'm in
the main section I'm in the Wow Wow
I saw that you're the [ __ ] out of me is
running away it was like witnessing a
horrible murder like oh yeah gee guys
there's a horse in here yeah there's
blood in the puppy crates ha ha ha ha ha
there's blood in all of them I see your
pain where are you legit stuck I'm legit
suck but I see your pain Wade yeah how
likely do you really think it is we'll
pick him out is it bad not hugely likely
but
like me it's clear the general area you
should be able to yeah I'm autumn pretty
easily does anyone want to see us
whenever I killed Jack you saw that and
1/1 player1 of you right now yeah I can
see one of you right now is it are they
jumping is it me no I made plus so it's
Wade look at what else I don't realize
that those all were actually from
Eastern egg tongue face okay I don't
know three strength
I guess there's Easter man it was so
funny wait when when I said I could see
you your head just turned like directly
towards me he was like a horror memory
cell thing like I have you not seen yeah
how have you not seen me you're both
bunch of idiots you're you're ugly
you're stupid
oh wow so losers you'll never have
happiness so now it did stand out once I
looked at it yeah it was the wrong kind
of box and he was in another box halfway
okay just a little off all right I mean
I got this all right jack listen closely
if you can hear the clacks of their
keyboards you can pick out what
direction they're going in ah yes yes
the key box just holding w-why does this
keep happening to me stop he stopped
keyboard technique he's like it's like
listening long steps and down the trail
please you got a look oh oh wait is
something happened horrible it's Ross I
like ya oh it's meshing with he's right
here
wait hang on let me see let me see the
horror where you at
it wasn't like this man I can't even
find you jack is it where you are see I
see you okay hang on oh god no I'm
[ __ ] song yes whale oh oh there you
her whoa attempt that why yeah why'd you
do that because I wanted to drive around
looking in award hey did you and I have
the same idea wait it's gonna take a
while
wait if I charge you up with my stun
baton oh no this is a different game
mode I don't have that
all right well you're almost out you're
almost out you're moving there's no way
you're moving man meeting the right one
new Ford be free this is mine
okay so what's it either hahahaha is it
me oh I'm half of the war there we go
all right okay Bob Bob could you see him
uh I could hear the shooting I could not
very directly
where's oh I'm in a bad way okay I made
a mistake you both made mistakes
mine was a bigger mistake uh-huh
it was a huge mistake hmm I think mines
gonna be fine
look ooh that doesn't sound fine not
yeah way doesn't have much confidence in
you it's gonna be fine okay
I think he's gonna be fun it's gonna be
me it's gonna be my have we walked past
you yet I was moving around for a long
time until I made it so that I cannot be
around him I would say that's always
teleported it's okay I like to twitch a
crappy connection yeah my terrible
internet must be to blame
Jesus oh Jesus okay I'm trying to get a
good van
Oh God yes you got any clues where is uh
I can see both of you currently okay
that means you're terribly close to me
but I can't add weight we're on opposite
sides of the map so if you can see both
of us that means you're probably yeah up
top and ooh or I were flipping the wall
oh he's stably money you could always
see both I know right nah but I don't
think that's it I think he was in a
position let's see in the last part he
mentioned there was a horse he must be
the horse oh I do shingle horse's penis
I'm good now oh no wait you can merge
the lorry
yeah take that Bob that's what you can
yeah I list this a clue back down ah
okay
all right well we win right we win we
win ah I um
I lift things ah so you are you a
forklift I tried to be a forklift but I
may or may not have succeeded wait
Oh found him wait oh come on oh wait
okay all right whoa what up what up what
up I'll trust you I'll trust you don't
run don't run come on got me you got me
Oh clearly but I really want to know if
you can become this crane thing in the
middle all right okay I want to like you
joking lying no I was I was a yellow
pushy dolly thing yeah mark you know he
thought I was a yellow dahlias dahlias a
dolly switch to a bucket I just I
freaked out we're trying to be the horse
try to be the horse to be the horse take
a cone is it even high enough for you to
get a fan if you can start moving that
around it's gonna be amazing
oh um well see I wasn't the horse and
marke marke can confirm I was not lying
yeah he was not lying when it would Bob
lie I never lie
oh come are you are you serious might
have [ __ ] up I i've definitely [ __ ]
up i had it in my oh my god or you tell
me [ __ ] is happening i know in like oh
no okay help
Oh help me I can't where am I I can't
slide what happened oh what happened oh
me
this sounds like it's going so watch
what happen to me see I can't see here
Bob
what happened what is this mark I'm okay
okay I might still have this you gotta
tell me what happened cuz survey machine
standing up by your inside of laying
down vending machine yeah I soon do
something like that cuz I can't see a
goddamn thing please just end my pain oh
god wait the tools here
yes took to to murder oh that's that's
clever Jack that's clever that's clever
it's alright that's clever right that's
clever letter you're a clever boy
ooh clever boy ever lever you're out
you're clever he's a clever wait a
second I have a question oh my god wait
what do you see what I just what how did
you weigh without whoa whoa hang on oh
my goodness ah there's a banana out
there yeah this is bananas a baby up
there
you saw I was like oh no I feel like
he's laughing at me a Wade there Jack
that was not a good move
it's time to stop Jack it's time to stop
hey you a clock yeah well I say I shot
gloop all the boxes then he was a clock
I'm a pilot
yeah it was were standing on me oh you
guys were like dancing on his face it
was awesome
damn it then you left I only I wanted to
move but I couldn't cause you want a
scene oh good god for Sunday's you hey
Palmer you I'm not doing anything leave
whatever Bob tries to do something
sneaky he gets really quiet Oh leave me
alone uh okay whoa what oh ha ha ha ha
I I hang on hang on hang on
I just experimenting I'm assuming it's
me that you're seeing and saying hello
to yes hi I'm experimenting hang on oh
no there's not went down here [ __ ] hang
on let me go jailer in let me go to the
other end I'll stay I'll say tea form oh
hi do I believe the street I feel like
that's game Ron what are you trying to
do Bob I want to see if I can become the
crane still and I can drop down on top
of that I don't think you can I highly
doubt you can become the crane yeah yeah
well uh
elbows perk my name go hide again okay
I'll try find a spot all right
oh wait sorry wait okay wait what ah
spot in top top corners right find uh
something major I'm watching one of you
is something back there I can push I can
push everything I don't trust it anymore
I'm watching like a hawk
you still can't push props I got eyes on
eyes on don't you go you were right here
he's still in there he hasn't moved he
hasn't gone away I
I'm a tiny box I may have become a tiny
box Bob whoa I saw movement out of my
right corner in that back storage area
I'm coming for you later
hahaha I saw that he said hi wait when
he came over here huh oh hi he's too
system tipos bag oh you guys didn't find
wait oh wait oh wait oh that's Wade okay
wait I didn't hit anything
someone's up there someone is but and
he's awfully quiet
I'm not awfully quiet oh sure awfully
quiet
I was oh hello I shot you right in the
head execution-style there were both he
posed so Bob and I had the same idea to
start the thing were you behind me when
that happened is how he said I was
trying to be in that I just dropped down
and read well they were looking at you i
maneuvered around them to get to the
back uh apparently we need to mix up the
strategies a little bit ways but it's I
was I supposed to do oh damn it I'd I'd
kill a lot of us I'm alone and now so
long mama I'm so lousy
hey hey out of that song go that I was
singing earlier oh my god can you become
this Oh No yeah I can't remember but
[ __ ] were you singing the Lord of the
Rings song no no no no hi
ah is that that Enya song it's something
like that
the grumps like we're doing it on their
most recent episode and I just haven't
been able to stop doing it ever since
then so Jack you're gonna die why you
done [ __ ] goof bruh you did the same
thing I tried to do it's hubris weight
or I don't know how you can't not see
him Jesus guys I I don't understand I
don't think any of them are near me Jack
my knee props go Jack
I don't like your disk i/o wait where
are they I like we look really dumb wit
ya there does oh wow
yeah Wow oh hey buddy on give you
another chance you ever not no no no
don't good you don't know no no don't do
it don't do it I can't even see anything
your friend here I don't hear anything
yes you eat everywhere yeah you can't do
it you're dang Fox right here here I'll
put it I'll put it on top of yous so you
got it
oh it's inside you you just end this
pain I didn't end the suffering and oh
wow
wow that's brutal easily hurt or at
least I'm not the only one who died like
an idiot yeah you died before the round
even stared yeah whatever
mmm what happens if you get stuck with
mark I don't know come on me I'm trying
I want to play the game just badly as
you yeah
I I just take it's it's harder for me I
didn't work as well as I'd hoped I'd I
don't know something about brain damage
I don't know yeah that's true I believe
that in a heartbeat okay
diggity darn it son okay I'll look up
top
Oh
surveyed I see one of them they're tiny
nope where I'm so badly just white whoa
a wrecking ball but didn't work all
right
at two damn it I keep trying stuff
that's not working this map is really
frustrating yeah it's hard to deal a
ball it says you got a suicide bomb well
ah whatever you were don't feel bad that
I lived longer than you it's actually
not a bad spot wait I don't know if
they're ever gonna look there
I'm sorry for shooting you so quick I
get paranoid that I'm not gonna find you
again and I don't want to win I mean I
was a tiny little can but I I did not
intend to run around I was trying to get
on top of the shelves of a boxes but you
can't get on or in those anywhere hmm if
they do look here Bob I think I blend in
very well yeah I think you're really uh
you really camouflage are you something
small or big
we got a market what got a good you've
got a good idea
suit of armor 73 we got a real thick
skin scanning the environment
you got thick skin fix good okay I think
we've got what's thick damn he thick so
what is him yeah it's got oh I'm about
how Bob would describe me I guess he
thick thick he thick though finger think
I'm done dad sick though what oh I saw
that banana fall down I was like huh oh
okay was it a cadet banana you get that
banana but you know that you Dan a thick
Oh what that be that's actually funny
because I went to the store and I wasn't
gonna buy a banana but this banana was
like a hybrid double banana
it was super like thick and extra girthy
so I bought it and uh or uh that's the
end of my story has this Animus result
the torian's mark oh wait wait whoa I
saw some got to LA he became a huge
success you drop that huge double banana
story on us it's like I don't even know
who you are you changed markup or yeah I
have that banana changed me and more
ways than one
I'll pay would life-changing banana talk
about how girthy something is you'd say
oh why wait wait look wait hey well be
out hang on he'll sell me
out yeah I'll tell you I'll take you to
Bob Bob hey I'm not dead you thought bob
was dead but why can't I choose all the
clever trick let's go let's go Amy wait
who is this Bob would describe those
good you think though you think who was
he he was uh I was a bald old man it was
a bald man with thick something he did I
mean damn oh I have yet skin that horse
takes after me if you know what I mean I
don't what are you talking about I don't
have boobs uh yeah I was born who says
ah shite balls
buh-buh-buh-buh hey Bob I found pub you
didn't find nothing what are you talking
about actually what are you talking
about it's making me nervous
there's one of them in this corner right
behind you Bob no socks it's bouncing
around all over the place we know there
weren't uh-huh Hey look at me look at me
ha ha ha ha
Jimmy out of nice right I tried to
distract J just didn't work Mac I trade
whoo yeah see I'm not I'm not last
I'm not hidden oh pretty out in the open
huh what is this do this I mean your
soda hidden oh man really wait did you
say soda it not yo machine again
no Naz it's order a word word disorder
yes sir he's a penis yeah I had eaten a
swords that that's not helpful at all
there's just it's almost like he's not
trying to help you when would I have
checked the entire map Jack I've been
here the whole time I'm dead man he's
all right he is very dead man you you
guys were one of you looked right at me
just a second ago must have been weighed
I've been in this corner so if it's me
it was in this corner
don't you face him you'd understand haha
blocks our faces
good I understand man oh man
ah you guys smell so good ha ha I love
watching you guys work it's just an
inspiration uh yeah the costume swore to
closing hints now you're just now you to
say different hints yes again so [ __ ]
Bop is also again